wholeness not really much to say besides
it's all there
is really
simple there is only
wholeness
how could it be
otherwise it's not possible for it to be
otherwise you'll notice wholeness has
that Capital
H so so it's not only whole with a W in
the sense that it's not
to it's not
separate it's
[Music]
nonu that it's
one but there's only that
Unity but it also has that Capital H
because of
whole because it's
no
nothing
void
empty
deep
well that's always
here it's always
already can never be
lost therefore all seeking is hilarious
and
futile because separateness is an
impossibility
whole with the capital H is the absence
of a separate individual a separate
me and that's the
Fulfillment that is always already here
prior to any
seeking any chasing of
experience wholeness is fulfillment
which is always and
already nothing
everything which is
this is the ultimate
fulfillment and it can't be found by
objectifying it can't be found by
boxing and in
that spelling of wholeness there's also
a zero and a one as the O and the
L
nothing everything is zero
oneing zero
oneing shuna
moning there's only
that
which is always and
already it's so
simple zero
wanting nothing
everything that's why that zero and that
one is
there one
second
m
[Music]
just let some of the community
mates that were in the shared space here
outside just let them know that I was
recording I have a little sign up on the
door that I put
up really such simple stuff and there's
really not much that can actually be
said
about the ineffable because it can't be
known it can't be objectified it can't
be held on to it can't be
attained it's just always what
is how can what always already
is be an
attainment that's literally
impossible how can you attain nothing
everything when that's what always
already
is that's why all seeking is completely
futile
and the zero and one
are a
great way of
saying emptiness
ising empty
Luminosity
Boundless
Energy
an Infinity that is so perfect and so
free that it
can
dream that there's a Center Point among
others
wholeness means no Center
points wholeness means
nonlocality means nonp
positionality
really simple right wholeness means
without
location it means without
position there are no locations or
positions
anywhere in what is
whole in what is no thing everything
in that's what this
is and it's always mystery it's always
ineffable
unspeakable can't put words or symbols
or math or science or religion or
anything no construct or concept can
ever touch
it
but every construct
concept
idea is still
it it's totally futile for no thing
to object or box
itself because it can't be done because
it's already everything is already
wholeness
a question in the live chat about
non-dual
awareness it's another way to describe
the
non-locality of what is this
it's another way to describe the
wholeness only that this
is there has been less use here with
words of awareness or
Consciousness those seem to have been
quite
appropriated in
ways and they themselves are
just
shelves on the way to nothingness or
emptiness everything
thinging they comfortable grounds that
ass self or me or seeker can rest on or
sit on or conceptualize
about or talk about states of awareness
or
Consciousness or shifts in awareness or
Consciousness or
levels or processes or Transformations
or
paths and
that just continues the illusion of
Duality which is not and that's what the
nonuel means it means not
to so there would be no such thing as a
subject and an
object there would just be
this
and
that whatever is hearing whatever is
looking that is nothing
everything without Gap without
separation without
distance all of those things are Just an
Illusion they're just a
dream
so getting caught on any
ground
any shelf any
box is another way that me
grabs and
avoids the reality of being no thing
everything
wholeness
is so simple so
ordinary that it's
overlooked
and it's so always
already that it's unbelievably simple
that it's already that and that it can't
be found through a
Pursuit
it's too simple and too ordinary it's
too
natural it's like
sky and
trees and insects and
[Music]
animals it's too natural and spontaneous
and ordinary and empty and ising it's
too
unbelievably simple and innocent it's
it's
that it's that puppy it's that kitten
it's that
baby it's that innocence it's that
non-locality that wholeness before all
of those conditioned ideas that have
that tension or contraction in the
body of I'm a separate
individual among other separate
individuals and I
lack and I must attain
worthiness nothing is always and forever
forever nothing it's always in Forever
wholeness and it's so
simple there are plenty of
cases
of babies
children that are not
conditioned and that have
never
not been
whole this is
where things seem to be
heading
with home
da decentralizing basic needs
infrastructures
enabling
freedom because when those basic needs
are
met and there's no forced entry into
the
Matrix monetary
earning
identity separation
system there is more spaciousness to
just simply be alive and to be this so
to be
death Al living or death
living
and so
those
simple
ordinary dog or
cat
animal plant
insect
baby child that's just innocence it's
just always
there and it can't be
lost but apparently
it can experience a contraction into a
me into separation into
lack and that's all what wholeness
is
it's all wholeness that is dreaming
me there's another question in the chat
about how can nothing be wholeness if
it's
nothing you can see it gets a bit
conceptual and
nonsensical you can insert
loops and PhD
jargon and philosophical
inquiry and all kinds of
nonsense because it's obvious that
nothing thing is wholeness it's obvious
that that's
everything it doesn't need some sort of
logical
mathematical
reasoning it's just obvious simple and
ordinary there's only wholeness there's
only nothing everying that's all that
there is nothing means non
local it means
everything it's really the death of the
elusory
questioner it's impossible for there to
be a questioner because it's
already
nothing that's asking the
question
the questioner is
nothing it's wholeness asking
questions it's
fulfillment or
unknowing asking
questions it's innocence asking
questions it's emptiness asking
questions that's why it's hilarious
that's why it's a joke that's why it's
so
comedic what is
already asking questions about how it
can
become it's a total hilarious
illusion
another question in the chat about it
all just our mind so is it all just our
mind and then experiencing
ourselves
so there's an apparent body there are
apparent bodies so nothing is
bodying
everything and the bodies apparently
have organs inside of the
skin like a heart and a brain and a GI
tract and a apparently the
brain has these eyes that are jutted out
perceiving and
so anything beyond that like mind or
Consciousness or
awareness is
adding an
idea it's just adding an
idea and what is being said is the
absence of adding
ideas the absence of an idea called mind
the absence of of an idea called
Consciousness the absence of an idea
called
awareness the absence of an idea called
experience experience is about a center
point there is no Center Point and how
could nothing be an experien
sir where does experience sit where does
it rest where does it
register it's just simply nothing
everything it's just Infinity
in not Infinity experiencing itself or
nothing experiencing
everything it's just
everything
Infinity there's not
two it's the most simple ordinary
raw not tuness
imaginable which is what always
is there's another
question are you in direct contact with
that nothingness if so what's it like so
this is about no one
it's about there not being a
you you is the same thing as there being
a center
point of experience of perception of
sensation thought
emotion there is no experiencer or
Center Point or you
the
thought happens to No One it happens to
no thing it just happens apparently a
thought is just an
apparent it doesn't happen to anything
it's just
apparent the sensation is just apparent
and there are plenty of people that are
obsessed with with boxing
phenomenology and saying oh my gosh
these are all the variations of
Sensations and variations of thought and
variations of emotion and variations of
feeling and it's so important to just
box and con compartmentalize and
conceptualize and what's being said here
is all those boxes all those
compartments all those Concepts
obsessing about those Concepts actually
creates
separation it becomes more about how
much I know let me impart my knowing
onto you about how you can best
experience there's no experiencer
there's no knower there's no Doer
there's no thing that is hearing that is
seeing no thing that is non-local that
is nowhere that is no one is seeing
hearing
thinking it's so simple it's just like
that pure innocent animal like that dog
or that cat or that baby it's just pure
simple and
ordinary all of these additional
ruminations are just
totally
futile
yes becoming is an illusion
yes just nothing happening
yeah it's beautiful it's simple it's
ordinary it's just nothing happening
it's not
extraordinary me or a Center Point want
to be special it wants its story to be
validated it wants to be
unique there's no
uniqueness or
specialness in infinity or wholeness
there's only
Infinity there's no
specialness the desire to be
special comes from or to become comes
from a place
of me it comes from an illusion that is
a center point that lacks and that
needs another question if there is
nothing no one then what is the
individual the individual is nothing it
is no
one the body is nothing it's no
one the individual is again just another
concept or box that was created it's
just another
idea it's
just
body and that is no thing or no one
bodying
another question but aren't you the one
who is
aware why is that wrong to
say it's just misleading in a
way
there's an obsession in a way in um
seeking culture and the spiritual
industrial complex or sick s i there's
just an obsession to be
aware there's an obsession with there
being a
you and a
you as a center
point so it's just
misleading that there is a you that is
aware is
misleading no
one is not
misleading no one is the purest form of
saying
absence of saying no me of saying
wholeness
only of saying only non-local
everything oh this is
interesting because in one of the last
episodes I've said that
OCD is obsessive Center
Disorder so like
me or a center point it's an obsessive
Center
disorder and there's also a comment
about Consciousness Obsession so it's
OCD is an obsessive Consciousness
Disorder so everything in
spiritual industrial complex and
seeking it's
about and even in Neuroscience
research it's just
about trying to say what is nothing and
it's not possible to say what is
nothing it's just not
possible
it's funny obsessive centered disorder
and obsessive Consciousness
disorder there's no Center
Point there's no you there's only no one
everything there's a question above that
so is it an ego
[Music]
illusion again ego is just another idea
or concept it's just in a way it's just
easier to just say me so is me illusion
yes me is illusion a center point is an
[Music]
illusion a position is an
illusion an identity is an
illusion now it's it still appears that
there's a driver's license or a passport
that has specific symbols on it that
that register to this specific body so
that it can move between the ucer
bounded nation
states but that's just an appearance and
it's just a
story it's just an add-on to what is raw
natural
spontaneous identityless locationless
everything so it's just nothing with all
of its
added symbols or ideas or identifiers or
attributes and then the 10,000 Things is
just being lost in those identifiers
attributes it's name form
differentiation
separation Concepts
ideas it's a ceasing of
objectification it's a ceasing of boxing
box box box box box box box box box box
box it's a ceasing of that it's a
ceasing of obsessing about meaning and
purpose
meaning and purpose belong to a me they
belong to a center point because
everything has to have significance
everything has to have
specialness how does
this
apply
special
to
me and then everything becomes about
object object object object experience
experience experience is all about me
and my story and specialness and time
and space and a journey that is
transformative that I finally can attain
wholeness or attain
nothing but it's always already
nothing so
simple Yes it really wants an object
yeah
yes and an object is kind of like
a it's like a
pacifier it's like a spiritual
lollipop it's just
something that it can
uh latch onto or grasp
onto to avoid the no thing
everything so as long as there can be an
obsessive Center or
compulsion with objects or experiences
or meaning and
purpose as long as there can be that
then there can be a
constant avoiding of the no thing
everything
so basically another way to say it is
that as long as there
is serious the appearance of a very
serious
geopolitical separation porn that is
happening between elusory bounded nation
states as long as me can obsess about
the
objects of that separation porn and yell
at and argue with apparent others about
what should be happening in that
separation
porn that is the one of the best ways
that holess can avoid itself or hide
from
itself which obviously it's wholeness
that is
meing that is
objectifying separate nation
States there's no separation there are
no nation states nation states are a
complete
illusion it's not to say that tradition
and culture can't be beautifully music
or can't be beautifully food can't be
beautifully celebrated because it
absolutely can there can easily be a
celebration of
culture
of
um this likes certain kinds of foods and
that's just the way it
is and there can be a celebration of
that and an enjoyment of that without
there being
a Obsession about separation porn there
will be a
whole episode on separation porn which
is a fascinating way that
it's that it's come up
to
discuss or give name to what
is
happening
because separation porn is one of the
best ways to
describe in a
sense
what's the way that me
ucer
hides the wholeness that is
already
there was a question about what
about space and galaxies it's just what
is just space and
galaxies what about pizza and
Burgers it's almost like the there's
just an obsession with what about this
and it's
like it's wholeness that's asking that
it's nothing that's asking that nothing
is asking what about space what about
galaxies what about
pizza
there's this massive hierarchy of values
and
and boxes and ideas and what's
dualistically good or bad or right or
wrong but the thing is is that wholeness
is unconditional love so it's all
unconditional love
appearing as a tree or appearing as war
or appearing as
Sushi this seems to really like
sushi and that's just what's appearing
that's just what's happening
apparently
interesting it's like another father to
tuck you in at night it's going to be
okay to
me yeah no
one is unconditional love it is
wholeness when the me is absent which is
always the
case there's a certain um uh like a
refrigerator hum of
become become become seek seek seek find
wholeness in
experiences that goes
away it's beautiful it goes away it
never was it's seen that it never was
there was never some sort of contracted
tension around oh become become seek
seek
and it's important to say that there's
not a center point that it's going to be
okay
to so it's not about it being okay or
not okay it's not about
that it's not about feeling a a blanket
of comfort it's not about that it's that
there is no one
home everywhere forever always there's
no one home there's no experien sir it's
just whatever is happening whatever is
arising it's just whatever is this in
whatever is ising it's just that that's
what is being said it's just simply
that there's nothing more that can be
added on to
that
there's another question so if you are
not
the experiencer Observer awareness and
are nothing no one what does this mean
or does it mean nothing and it just is
yes it just means nothing and it just is
it means
nothing it means
nothing it's very
important because as soon it can can me
can latch on and begin creating all
kinds of meaning about
it and there there would still be a
center point that is trying to put no
one on a shelf and say this is an
attainment cuz it's not a there's no
shelf there's no shelf to to place
anything
on there's no registar or file
system it's just
ising and then there's
also no
meaning by the nothing and wholeness
that everything already always
is now I said this in a previous
episode that the
ultimate morality or ethics or change
that the world
needs does not come from me it does not
come from a center point that is trying
to manipulate control or change the
appearance in its Paradigm of duality of
right and wrong or good or bad it is
actually the ultimate morality ethics
change that the world needs comes from
the wholeness that is already it comes
from no one or
nothing because when clear that it's no
one or
unknowing
everything then it's just natural and
spontaneous that the body builds Dows or
decentralize autonomous organizations or
it builds in the Paradigm or for the
Paradigm of wholeness for the Paradigm
of unconditional love for the Paradigm
of non-separation which is not a
paradigm but it's just the Natural State
the natural way that the body is
spontaneous is wholeness and so that's
why
dawing like we're doing with home Dow
that is a natural emergent phenomena of
wholeness me can never
ever
have
any change that the world needs because
it will always be from a center point it
will always be from a self it will be
from a
me even if
me holds an idea of unity it's just a
Unity of separate
Mees and there there's no that's why
it's not two or non-duality it's not
Oneness or Unity because Oneness or
Unity still leaves room for individuals
or mes that are separate that are in a
Unity or in a Oneness which is not
what's happening it's not
that that's a common level that is
discussed in spirituality but it's not
that it's that there is only no one
everything there's only no one hessing
there's only that there's only
non-locality there's only
non-locality there's no separate Center
points that are
Oneness there's no separate Center
points and that answers the next
question about what's the value in
seeing the world in this way does it
feel good is it to the end of suffering
first of all there is no world first of
all the world is an appearance there's
only nothing everything in the world is
simply an
appearance
and
the what was said previously about the
ultimate morality ethics and change that
the world needs
balloons
again
um
that wholeness is that wholeness is
effortlessly naturally
spontaneously
dawing it just
does because there's obviously no me
there's 's obviously no Center Point
there's
obviously
non-locality and so when non-locality is
obvious which is the natural way that
everything is then there's just a a
spontaneous way that the
body moves in the way that it
builds what appears as the future of
Earth the centralizing basic
needs enabling Freedom love prosperity
it all of that's just the story no one
or no hearing right now nothing
hearing that's
it what is sought is
nothing
hearing that's what
s
no
one
watching no one
watching is
nonlocal
wholeness simple stuff
really
some more comments here there's just
home it's completely natural yes
exactly and it's always just this
whatever it
is whatever it is it's always home it's
always this
it's always wholeness appearing as
this it's
ising another comment I am loving this
have you had Emerson nonduality on
simulation he is super clear like
you I know of Emerson and I like Emerson
content so have not had him on the show
yet it's a fun
recommendation I'll reach
out that'd be
fun there is quite a
Focus right now
on just these streams as well
as it's exciting exting being in Austin
and having access to the
comedic wheel that comes through here
and getting comedians coming on the show
to Banter about this
exact
non-topic just the sheer Ridiculousness
of everything so there is an excitement
about
that and there's been a good amount of
DM an Outreach for that already so we'll
see how that goes it's exciting it's so
exciting there is another question here
so we are it or is there no such thing
as a Wii yes there's no such thing as a
Wii there's only nothing everything
there's no
we now the language can appear if there
is
whatever two or three apparent bodies in
a living room that are all leaving to go
somewhere and it's like hey can we get
going you know so it can appear as
language um for whatever is happening
apparently but it there's no
um I me you we they all of those
are boxes of of Separation in a way and
no thing
everything or wholeness
ising what's hearing
this that is no
one and no one is
non-local so there's no
we and they has been such a a
fascinating engine for separation
porn there was
uh perhaps it was maybe five six years
ago when the show was kind of lifting
off
and there were a good amount of guests
that would say they it would always be
about they are manipulating or they are
you know whatever um the global ruling
class or whatever they they they they
and this would frequently ask like what
do you mean by they who exactly are you
talking about and there would never be
an
answer and nowadays in
2023 they has become the probably the
most popular way of generating
separation
porn
they they are the
enemies that one they are the
enemies
there is no they there is no
they and that's the one of the last
things that me wants to hear is that
there's no they because it undermines it
cuts Duality at its
root there just is no
they what is an appearance of a global r
ruling Elite is just no one
everything the
2,200 billionaires are just the same no
one
everything although it appears like
there is a lot of me that is greedy and
centerp pointing
and it's fascinating because
nature nature
is
beautifully distributed and
decentralized it's
beautifully
constantly mirroring or
reflecting to no thing it's
constantly like there's only
these resource exchanges that happen
underground
between like trees and
mushrooms for
example this is something that
we that I wrote about in high level
perception three years ago
that
symbiosis is not being mirrored in the
me because the me is a center point and
there's no Center points in trees and
mushrooms there's no Center
points so if there's um a if there's a
sequestering of additional let's say
resources there's a distribution of the
additional resources to those that need
it it's actually way too simple all of
this is too simple and all of this
languaging it makes it more complex
where it's actually very
unneeded
exactly it's just absolutely unneeded
all of the extra language and complexity
and jargon and Concepts
and there's it's just simple it's way
too simple it's like the way that nature
effortlessly uh distributes resources as
a harmonic whole is
hilariously um human separation
apparently is uh siloed into Center
points of me that are hoarding and
greedy and caring about funding their
milit Ary industrial complexes of their
ucer B barded borded Nation States
bordered nation
states and fighting against an imaginary
other fighting against an imaginary
they fighting against an imaginary they
or an imaginary other is the primary
separation
porn
it's ridiculous
man if there is no one nothing what is
consciousness that's what has been said
multiple times Consciousness awareness
mind brain body whatever you want to say
that's no thing that's no
one
there's another question here are you
going to do shrooms again or
psychedelics there's always questions
about
this first of all there's no knowing
anything there's just no knowing
anything it's just this apparent
spontaneous effortless
flow the most trippy thing imag
is a center point in
Infinity the most trippy thing
imaginable is wholeness apparently
Contracting into a sense of me that
lacks something that's always
forever already
fulfilled that apparently lacks needs
and seeks and then uses things like
psychedelics or traveling or books or
gurus or substances or relationships or
whatever to try to become whole that's
the most trippy thing
imaginable so the most natural and
ordinary thing is obviously emptiness
ising is obviously the most natural
thing the most unnatural
thing if we were to create a distinction
which there isn't one is a center point
is a
me yeah there's some comments about is
this solipsistic philosophy and then
there's a comment after it's philosophy
of
non-dualism
yeah again these are just words and the
words are
just the all language all symbols all
Concepts ideas it's all just extra boxes
and add-ons and stuff to this there's
just this what is hearing this voice is
nothing
everything that's
it this
that's it
this whatever is apparently appearing
that's it that's it there's nothing more
that's
it bird
flying it's just what is water
drinking
another question about but what about
for fun well whatever just spontaneously
like music
happens comedy clubs
happen playing out in the
sun petting the dogs and the cats
cracking jokes with friends
it's just effortless fun effortless it's
like the Innocence of the
child that was
always innocent non-local whole
playful
bantering and this is just the story but
prior to all of that contractive
conditioning by parents teachers Society
IDE
ologies you are your name you are
separate from that separate individual
with their name and you have to earn
worthiness you have to earn validation
you have to become whole by proving
yourself and there goes the spiral of
becoming you
know
there's another question about so then
what is perspective
well again simple
unknowing
unknowing it's way it's way too it's way
too
simple unknowing
is no thinging which is non-local which
is
is perspective or perception before
there's a comprehending entity me or
Center Point or
experiencer it's just always already no
thing
everything
yeah there's a comment there in the chat
about uh exploring uh nism there's the
um isness which is no separation between
nothing and
something it's really
simple there's no separation or
difference between nothing and an
apparent
me it's just
this
and it's obvious why
it's hard or difficult
for
me which is obsessed with boxing and
trying to figure it out trying to know
its way to unknowing it's not possible
how can you add or
attain to what is already empty
unknowing you can't get to what is
already empty unknowing you can't get
there because it already
is that's why this donated all of its
books
there's nothing left to get from a
book another good way to say it is
there's no
shelf no nothing has no shelf where an
attainment of a gold star of
Enlightenment or Awakening where it can
sit and be applauded and awarded
there's no
shelf there's only nothing there's no
shelf nothing can be added no attributes
or identifiers or anything nothing can
be
added
and just to be clear if there's a a
good um recipe for some sort of
soup
and it can arise to read a a recipe of a
soup or look it up on the internet and
and make it
but it's just what's
happening it's always already just
what's
happening another good way to say it is
me is more me equals more
more more more
more instead of just being
The Emptiness that's
ising it tries to
fill of vacuity or
void
and it's impossible to
fill a
void
it's can only be the
void that's
everything there's only being the void
that's
everything there's impossible to
fill void that's everything impossible
and so me is stuck in a stinky Little
Pond of trying to
fill
void and it can't no attainment or
experience or addition or substance
relationship
travel Guru psychedelic anything nothing
will ever satisfy it'll never fulfill
because it wants an object or something
to fulfill it but it's already made of
Unknowing it's already made of emptiness
it's already made of
fulfillment
probably
will end this episode
soon and perhaps we'll sign on again and
stream
later probably have
[Music]
some sunny side up
eggs
bit of H Salt and
Pepper cooked in
butter one of my
faves
that's a good comment something is
really a minuscule part of everything is
hardly worth mentioning
yeah anything that can be boxed or
objectified or something ified is hardly
worth
mentioning boundlessness is so infinite
it's so pure it's so spontaneous natural
beautiful perfect free
unconditional that to be obsessively
compulsively boxing and objectifying and
samifying is just such a contraction in
the in the body and then therefore in
the
appearance
it's beautiful when no one just Roars
when no one just
Roars and just cuts that dualistic root
of me because me will try to control and
manipulate the
appearance and then when nothing or
collie is just like you don't exist
you're not real there is no me
then there's no longer a a
doorm there's no longer
an uh it's no one is unmanipulated
so if there is nothing no one it's
another comment then what is the
evolution of Consciousness about
then Discovery and inventions
compounding based off of
knowing well evolution is just an
appearance it's just an
appearance it's just what's apparently
happening
and just to be clear nothing doesn't
evolve nothing or
wholeness zero oneing doesn't
evolve it
ises evolving would be becoming it
doesn't become it
ises
apparently
and there's an appearance of a
microphone and a computer and a camera
which appear to
be modern
inventions but that itself is part of a
story called
time and time is just an appearance
evolution is just a story story it's
just an
appearance so it's just what is this
microphone the computer the camera this
is why the da home da in the developer
Network there's a lot of scientists
there's a lot of Engineers there's a lot
of
inventors nothing everything
in is is not about
not doing it's not about not science
it's not about not inventing it's not
about not engineering it's not about
making not making better advances in
technology it's not about
that actually decentralizing basic needs
infrastructures is a lot about nothing
everything in an appearance of creating
better
Technologies free
energy
beautiful solar
Punk
style future
housing communal
builds food
forests water
wells just everything imaginable in
those communal spaces all kinds of
sports all kinds of art entertainment
comedy play
relaxation spa whatever
imaginable and then you have
the those the bodies can live in
houses in those modern houses and and
it's um it's it's just it's in it's
really Indescribable the best way to do
it is to go to the homed dow.com and
look at the white paper it took a long
time to put together that white paper um
which is the tokenomics it's the
mechanism behind the Dow so the da isn't
owned by anyone it's owned by no one and
everyone and it just enables you know
tokens that are backed by the real world
basic needs
infrastructures
so it's it just it just seems and just
appears that there's
a there's just a beautiful everything's
beautiful everything's perfect
everything's free everything's normal
and ordinary and thisn everything is
that and then as no one everything
becomes clear which it always is so as
me unwinds and untangles its
Neurosis then
dawing decentralized autonomous
organizing becomes more apparent in the
appearance it's another way to say
it
I spoke of wrapping up and there's been
a ramping up of the chat
okay thanks for tuning
in appreciate the love and Community
it's always
beautiful
H
yeah is there that comment is what was
just said that the an evolution or
Consciousness is a story and that when
there's glimpses of
Unknowing of non-locality of no thing
everything then there's all kinds of
narratives that come up oh there's
levels there's all kinds of levels and
maps and there's all kinds
of of uh things that need to
be transformed and
um and healed and all kinds of uh of
therapy
and and again this isn't
saying uh whatever arises if therapy is
arising or if healing is
arising it's just what's arising it's
just what
is it's just that the the the healing or
the therapy or whatever is arising isn't
the cause of
wholeness that's what's being shared
wholeness is always already and then
it's appearing as a me that is on a
journey of healing to become whole but
it's all but it's made of
wholeness it's ridiculously
funny
oh yeah basically apparently
happens
you yeah and there's basically a
pretending to be not
nothing not
everything that's what me essentially is
is is pretending to not be
nothing pretending to not be
everything
yes it's so funny it's so
cute it's it's so and it's such a small
stinky Pond of me
pretending to not be
nothing it's only true
for the experience of
me and it's
absolutely made of
nothing so as soon as that apparently
contracted me glimpses it being no thing
everything all of its neurosis and
stories and seeking
and not being whole all of those things
dissolve they disappear and it was clear
that they never were
the me never was the contraction never
was the separation never was the lack
never
was the name identity location Center
Point never
was there was only no thing
everything emptiness
ising is
ising
[Music]
is how would y'all spell
ising
ising is a bit
too simple in a
way I like that spelling too but I I
like i z z iing g it's just been it's
kind of like a more funny funky way to
spell it ising I ZZ iing G
ising yeah I like that I easy ising oh
that's funny all the Z's there's like
six Z's in there
ising oh and without a g Isen it's
Isen infinite
is
Isen yeah because there's nowhere to go
from Isen there's nowhere to go you
can't get somewhere from Isen Isen is
just this it's just
this
there's nowhere to go from this from
Isen there's nowhere to go from
it and so it doesn't give any lollipops
to the Seeker it doesn't give any
Pathways for the me to expand or
transform
is
glad you're having
fun call it
cute
yes I say so myself so
cute yeah that that calm
voice
yeah that's part of this
apparent unwinding of
me is calm relaxation
relief what was said earlier as like
this refrigerator hum of become become
earn worthiness become whole become
whole get
fulfillment that thing's
gone so obviously there's just
this
yay
yeah those little confetti emojis that's
right the dance party of
isness the dance party of isness uh uh
dance party
of
is dance partty of
isness let's whip out the fish Dr the
wood
block the dance poty of busness uh uh uh
the dance party of isness uh uh uh the
dance party of business yeah yeah the
dance party of isness what what dance
party of isness You Know It dance party
of isness yeah yeah dance party of
isness Yeah dance potty of
isness just simply
appearance just simply appear
just simply
appearance so easy just simply
appearance what's appearing is
isness what's appearing is
isness what's appearing is ising ising
ising ising ising ising is is isness
ising
ising is is in ising ising the dance
party of buiness what what the dance
party of isness what what the dance
party of isness what what
unconditional love of isness yeah yeah
unconditional love of isness the freedom
freedom of isness yes yes Hess of of
isness woo wo no of isness yeah yeah
everything of business yeah
[Music]
yeah all the cute emojis of hearts and
confetti yeah so we'll we'll be jamming
out out more I like that on these on
these
streams which
I'm which I'm really excited
for this
uh this is definitely one of
my one of my
favorites the wood block
drum so first uh discovered in bodaya in
India at mahabi where Buddha was
enlightened there were uh monks from B
southeast
Asia I've said this on a previous
episode but sat with them for some hours
as as
uh they were chanting and
drumming so if you're interested and
like to be silly and spontaneous and
playful and Musical and this is a nice
one cuz it's just that it's like that
perfect the dance body of
is you know it's got that great sound
and um Cadence it's got you know it's
got that it's really nice it's kind of I
guess is Indescribable in a way I guess
it's so simple like it's not like some
big um like multiharmonic
thing that has a whole bunch of
equipment or whatever it's just
something so simple as like a tiny like
wood block drum dot dot dot dot dot dot
dot you know say the simple and
ordinariness of it in a
way m
oh that's funny
that uh not knowing what to ask
yeah it's just what is you know it's
what's apparently happening
and that's just unknowing it's you know
it's like the questioner the
Seeker of getting something isn't there
and there's like this huge in a way
relief into the wholeness that always
is into the non-locality and simplicity
that always
is
yeah there's
another comment about yeah is and isn't
yes what is and
isn't neither real nor
unreal
not
solid
ungraspable
it's like trying to
grab air or a
rainbow or water
just can't do it
and and there's no point
to only me
is undergoing that futile
effort all right that was
fun fun stream on
wholeness wholeness with that Capital
H for
whole and the zero and
one for the no thing
everything for that zero
oneing that
[Music]
ising
zinc
okay well that's all for
now thanks for tuning in Cutie
Pies
sweethearts sugar
plums
M and thanks for the fun interaction in
the
chat and we'll be back on with another
stream
soon okay
bye-bye see
[Music]
you ready so
cute